how do you prevent your spouse from
cheating on you try to maintain
connection with your partner I don't
believe people cheat when they're happy
I've rarely seen people cheat to hurt
the other person usually what it is is
they go out and they like the affection
of this other person they like the
attention of this other person and then
they cross lines they shouldn't have
crossed and they're not doing it to hurt
their partner they're doing it to make
themselves feel good and they're not
thinking about their partner which they
should be doing at that moment like I
don't eat chocolate cake cuz I want to
screw my diet no like I want to eat
chocolate cake cuz chocolate cake tastes
good I can eat healthy choices that are
going to be good for me and the next day
I'll feel good or I can go out and eat
terrible food that's going to make me
feel bad an hour but man it tastes good
and trust me adultery tastes good it's
new it's novel it's something different
come on gang like let's all just be
honest with each other but is it what
you want no it's garbage it's junk food